[Music]
all right abc news now reporting at this
hour the doj's watchdog michael horowitz
is coming out strong against james comey
andrew mccabe loretta lynch in his
forthcoming report
which examines how obama's justice
department and fbi
well mishandled the 2016 criminal case
into hillary clinton in other words
we were right and your media was wrong
of course fired fbi director james comey
he cleared hillary clinton of all
charges
but not before many public missteps
misdeed surrounding the investigation
according to the report quote one source
telling abc
that the draft report explicitly uses
the words
insubordinate to describe comey's
behavior now the i.t report will also
allegedly rebuke loretta lynch and fire
deputy fbi
director andrew mccabe none of this is
surprising remember
the mccabe report came out then comes
the criminal referral
after all we know about comey's
exoneration before investigation we know
about loretta lynch's illicit tarmac
meeting with bill clinton just before
she helped clear his wife of all these
charges and we all know about mccabe's
democratic ties and
rampant pattern of lying and we also
know hillary clinton
she did commit felonies she did obstruct
justice
that is indisputable at this point now
as we reported last night andrew mccabe
he's now requesting immunity
from the u.s senate in exchange for his
testimony possibly against his former
boss james comey
now the full unredacted report should
literally have been released by now and
frankly if it's released anytime between
now and next wednesday remember we have
the summit on tuesday of next week
that means they're trying to bury this
on a summer weekend
so it doesn't get the coverage it
normally would if they release it early
next week
they are totally trying to bury this
during this all-important summit in
singapore
now what americans deserve what you
deserve is justice in the form of
criminal referrals for everybody we just
mentioned
it has been 18 long months and mr
obstruction himself of congress
rod rosenstein he has had this report
for two weeks already
and i can only imagine what he's trying
to get removed or changed or redacted
our own catherine herridge has a new
report about fbi lovebird one of the two
peter strzok in this case remember he
was the agent demoted after his rampant
anti-trump text became publicly
available
our own catherine herridge is reporting
that he was actually the lead
investigator
in this clinton case he hated trump he
wanted the insurance policy
and then he moved on to the russia
so-called russia collusion case
and then he was put on mueller's
witch-hunt team in other words this
trump-hating fbi agent
played a lead role in pretty much
completely everything
including clearing hillary clinton of
charges
crimes we know she committed and then
tapped to investigate donald trump
one more reason the inspector general's
report should have been released by now
and meanwhile as the mueller witch-hunt
turns on the special counsel
this is interesting they are demanding
that witnesses turn
in their phones so team mueller and of
course his pitbull
andrew weissman and jeannie ray who work
for clinton
get to review all of their electronic
communications he wants the phones
turned over
even texts that are on what are called
encrypted
apps like whatsapp or signal or one of
these things
now maybe mueller's witnesses i don't
know if i advise them to follow hillary
clinton's lead
delete all your emails and then acid
wash
the emails and hard drives on the on
your phones
then take your phones and bash them with
a hammer to little itsy bitsy
pieces use bleach bit remove the sim
cards and then take the pieces and hand
it over to robert mueller
and say hillary rodham clinton clinton
this is equal justice under the law
how do you think that would work out for
everybody who mueller's demanding their
phones of tonight
now i'm certain the result would not be
the same as hillary's and meanwhile the
person in charge of this mueller witch
hunt
the deputy a.g rod rosenstein he has
responded to growing calls for his
recusal
writing a letter to senator senator
lindsey graham stating he will recuse
himself if deemed appropriate
and he recommended he's the guy that
recommended comey's firing he
signed off on the final fisa warrant
based on hillary clinton's bought and
paid for dossier
that even christopher steele said there
may be 50 50.
so given that rosenstein is overseeing
an investigation where he's a key
witness
and he signed off on the fisa i think
it's probably deemed inappropriate a
long time ago
and earlier today former new york city
mayor current trump attorney rudy
giuliani had very strong words
for the seemingly never-ending fishing
expedition
to undo the election of you the american
people
watch what the former mayor had to say
they are
a group of 13 highly partisan democrats
that make up the mueller team
excluding him are trying very very hard
to frame him to get him in trouble when
he hasn't done anything wrong now they
may not know they're doing it
they may not realize they're doing it
but they can't they
they can't emotionally come to grips
with the fact that this whole thing of
russian collusion
didn't happen right that they're trying
to invent theories of obstruction of
justice
the president fired the fbi director the
president has the right to fire the fbi
director
the president should have fired the fbi
director he was a terrible fbi director
even comey said he had right to fire up
we'll get back to the switch hunt in a
minute also tonight bad news for the
trump-hating mainstream media
they're rampant disgusting conspiracy
theories about our first lady melania
trump
being missing in action came all
crashing down today as the first lady
appeared
alongside her husband at an event in
washington d.c
so much for the conspiracy theories take
a look
i'd like to sort of maybe say
and pay some respects to some of the
people here today i have a list
of course we have to start with our
great first lady melania
thank you melania
she went through a little rough patch
but she's doing great and we're very
proud of her she's done a fantastic job
as first lady the people love you
people of our country love you so thank
you honey
i'm glad she's healthy and by the way
her approval ratings are higher than the
president's
now also the president delivered a very
special message uh for the media today
on twitter writing the fake news media
has been so unfair so vicious to my wife
our great first lady melania during her
recovery from surgery they reported
everything from near death
to facelift to she left me in the white
house for new york or virginia
to abuse all fake and she's doing really
well
all right let's turn our attention now
to kim kardashian
okay you didn't expect me to say that
did you now she visited the oval office
as you know recently to shine a light on
the criminal justice system and reform
in particular
and one case involving alice marie
johnson who was a great grandmother
remember she was sentenced to life in
prison
after being found guilty of nonviolent
drug charges
it was only a first offense today
president trump commuted the sentence of
miss johnson
who has already served 22 years
a few hours ago kim kardashian thanked
the president writing quote so grateful
to at real donald trump
jared kushner and to everyone who showed
compassion and contributed
countless hours to this important moment
for miss alice marie johnson
her commutation is inspirational and
gives hope to so many others who are
also
deserving of a second chance and of
course by the way this is likely just
the beginning
of what is a long needed conversation in
this country about sentencing criminal
reform
that the president has vowed to tackle
this two-tier justice system
that we now know way more than we should
about it stretches wide and it's
stretches far these issues must be
addressed
equal justice under the law equal
application of the laws
by the way we do wish ms johnson all our
best tonight
and meanwhile someone who has actually
benefited from a two-tier justice system
speaking of which his whole entire life
former president bill clinton yeah he's
back in the spotlight believe it or not
he's finally facing some backlash from
the mainstream media
and democrats over his long history of
sexual abuse and misconduct
and democrats in the media remember they
protected the clintons
all through the last presidential
campaign that is until november 9
2016 the day after hillary lost
remember this do you think differently
or feel more responsibility
no i felt terrible then
and i came to grips with it did you ever
apologize
no yes and nobody believes that i got
out of that for free
i left the white house 16 million
dollars in debt
but you typically
have ignored gaping facts
and descripting this and i bet you don't
even know them do you feel i thought
over and over no
i do i i i do not
i've never talked to her but i did say
publicly on more than one occasion that
i was sorry
i dealt with it 20 years ago plus
and the american people two-thirds of
them stayed with me
and i've tried to do a good job
since then with my life and with my work
that's all i have to say to you now
following that interview bill clinton
actually trashed nbc news for finally
asking a tough question
kind of questions they should have asked
during the campaign in 2016
and they fired back take a look the
former president bill clinton expressing
some regret over his controversial
remarks about monica lewinsky here on
today
but still making false allegations about
that interview
with craig overnight the former
president said that his interview with
us
was not his quote finest hour speaking
with mr colbert mr clinton made another
public apology for his behavior during
the monica lewinsky scandal
but also took issue with the questions
we asked him earlier this week
i think the tape speaks for itself you
of course did not assert that he never
apologized you asked whether he had
apologized thank you very much
of course nbc news the rest of the media
is about 30 years too late remember
they gave bill clinton a complete and
total pass until
his wife lost the election right here on
hannity we did call out clinton's
alleged sexual assault year after year
way before the me too movement and way
before the left seemed to care about his
misconduct you might remember this
you described the scene where he was
biting on your lip and then when it was
all over
he was leaving
said you better put some ice on that
yeah
and casually put on his sunglasses and
walked out the door
it was a terrible ordeal for me and i
no woman should be subjected to it it
was an assault
he assaulted you yes he and you he
touched grab
fondled and kissed you against against
your will and it's an allegation that is
not made by
one woman it's made by multiple many of
us i said well
i may need to be going or something and
next thing you know he pulled down his
he sit down pulled pulled down his pants
his whole everything
and he was exposed and i said i'm not
that kind of girl
and i need to be getting back to my to
my desk i wanted a broderick interview
one of the hardest i've ever done
in the 23 and a half years here at fox
only one more example
proving that we will never be the
mainstream media we do care about people
the american people
we cover the stories they just refuse to
because they're so politically oriented
agenda driven these are issues that
should transcend politics finally
tonight
we finish with yet another amazing piece
of economic news perhaps the best ever
for the first time since the stat
started
recording the united states has more
jobs
today than jobless claims
get that we have more more jobs
available than we have people on the
unemployment lines
on top of that we have 14 states today
with record low unemployment numbers
and record low unemployment for women
african americans hispanic americans
now remember if this was the obama
administration i guarantee you
chris matthews would be having a lot of
thrills running up and down his leg
it'd be non-stop 24-7 but this president
did promise you jobs jobs and more jobs
and 501 days guess what he's delivering